how to make sure that you are a failure
Charlie Munger in one of his seminal
speeches he talks about how to guarantee
failure you have to make sure that
you're inconsistent because if you are
consistent and you have none of the
other attributes you still might be
successful it's very tough for people
who are consistent to not be successful
in my opinion it's one of the most
difficult of the virtues for humans to
do because we're so attracted to novelty
I used to do with this with people on
their diets all the time I remember I
ran gyms someone would come in and I
would always ask the question so have
you been following the meal plan and
then they would say yes and so then I
started changing the way I asked the
question out of the 21 meals that you
were supposed to eat how many of the 21
did you have exactly the way it was on
the meal plan and then they would be
like at least half and they would say it
as though that was a mark of success
right now the meal plan could be your
content plan it could be your showing up
to work on time plan if there's one
muscle that you can Flex it's learning
to do the same thing over and over again
one of the values that we had at gym
launch is do the boring work because
boring is what makes you rich